hey guys I'm great John so we got so
many requests blowing up the wazoo yeah
for the new it trailer but I'm only
going to shout out the first person who
requested it telling you so many demands
crazy comments for it [ __ ] but the first
one Godzilla king of the monsters the
king it trailer bed it's a great comment
sorry it was the first one person before
we filmed this want to give one last
mention I was in a pilot presentation
for a thing called ghost hunter diaries
I have a supporting role in the pilot
you should go watch that video
people have been checking it out I'm
really liking it so it's a war movie so
I figured I'd promote it here anyway
what's the not being around the bush
will give her insight see I would saw
the original and want to go to Ulysses
dudes
Tim Curry in curry creepies gone like a
young dog
I'm going to super kid
ouch
oh we're gonna remember this
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
it's all connected by three
[Music]
[Applause]
oh boy cool trailer yeah cool trailer
does look like the updated remake of
everything the 1990 original they're
doing this like a two-part movie right
because the book to my understanding it
has like two distinct part yeah and
they're kids and then they grow up and
they come back yeah her kid and then
like 30 years later they come back oh
don't take on the Pennywise and i still
have the thing with Stephen King movies
like whenever we come back and relate
we're gonna do really good take the book
thank you well the the miniseries I
heard was decently faithful and it was
like a two-part miniseries as well so
maybe this I I don't know if they can
the original plan to make it a
two-parter here's when cary fukunaga
Ojinaga was a part of it he wanted it
for sure to make it a two-parter yeah I
don't know if that's still the original
plan
yeah I only saw the original once when I
was like six years old yeah I don't
really I remember it to the tee but I
remember those sewers it like a look at
who they're gonna be updated like look
of it all you know we're in that day and
age were like oh this is the modern day
reboot touch it has a much darker visual
style more realistic rounded approach to
what I think anyone feels rather campy
and I never read the book that's based
on here this doesn't feel so campy this
is out it drills down red red dreadful
yeah that induced dreadful [ __ ] eerie
and I mean people were questionable
about the clown when they saw the image
release watching him a movement is yes
lots of airier burnishers wise looks
pretty creepy I mean like I like the old
design that they went with personally
like any of them if you're gonna update
something do it different and go back in
time yeah I don't know I think he looks
like a really creepy penny line well I
feel like this one could get a lot more
visual visually creepy because I know
that it plays on you know your your your
biggest fears in your phobia it works
towards your imagination so those nasty
things living in your hand yeah so as
much as like I want to see as much of
anywise the clown as much as possible
I'm also thinking they're going to go
wander really it yeah they're going to
go a lot crazier with their fears and
phobias that they're having and that's a
teaser too so we only saw them as kids I
don't like I said I don't remember if
it's going to be a part 1 or part 2 from
what I lost read it was still supposed
to be two movies and vision is that so
maybe this one just will focus on them
it's when they're when they're kids
yeah the loser group when they're
children losers I mean this is them
production for a while but yeah yeah
there's one of those ready make sure we
were like I'm not sure this is ever
getting it done yeah that's lucky for
them that stranger things came yeah I
get our borrowed one the kids everything
stranger things down it just doesn't
have the stranger things music which I'm
happy about because every movie or
trailer seems to have that 80 sci-fi I
think oh I didn't I'm like yeah okay we
got the kids thing but you know it does
it doesn't seem like it's trying to be
stranger things that I kind of eights do
yellow and things I guess they were
trying they were trying to do this
they're working on this iteration before
stranger things dropped and got huge a
thing so like it's fortunate for them
that they went to you know a story at
least in this part that has a lot of you
know centers around kids yeah yeah you
know the scary situation well like I
said I don't really remember the
original original the sewer scene I
remember the red balloon remember in
curry like yeah yeah I don't remember
the projector seen in the original
without either way rich or not that was
a really cool moment freaky set as a
freaky freaky bike I can just imagine
that like you're watching off you're
just especially the kid you know you're
using a projector and then the letters
are game changing as a clown's
appearance and freak you an analog
technology does yeah not supposed to
issue this is gonna be an r-rated flick
and I like saying mean abathur it's kids
that are the stars of this yeah they're
willing to kill off kids in this movie
tonight so if you can kill off kids and
do that then you got a scary movie in
your hands only kids are alright yeah I
hope they're able to go as dark as they
as the illy source material calls for I
haven't read the book yet either I like
the look of everything it looks creepy
and dreading and stuff like that I
didn't like a door mama but you know I
thought that guy had some shops and I
watched it yeah so I'm interested to see
the cary fukunaga script is still at
least somewhat intact so like we'll get
to see some of the stuff they were
working on before Oh totally was hands
and everything I'm well but he wasn't
directing still yeah I know he really
wanted to do it yeah yeah like he was
really invested in that what I'm really
hoping for from this videos it's just a
teaser trailer and you know you got to
give us the scares and the creepy parts
and everything and it's been a while
since a good Stephen King adaptation has
been brought to the big screen you know
been quite a while since we've got like
a well-regarded Stephen King adaptation
on like at the cinema why I'm really
okay with this being remade is because
the first one was a mini-series on TV
you know we haven't gotten the big
cinema annotation yeah here though I'm
very much okay with like them doing a
film adaptation of it from seeing the
visual style you're like yeah alright
cool your make it worth our time I don't
want to just watch the original like I
want to see what they do with this one
day I'm curious what what tricks you can
bring to the animal years later now what
might be relevant now with it was
different then and then all sorts of
stuff you know and what I like with
Stephen King stories is they're very
character-driven moody eerie other
depressing Aled kids a writer his sonís
characters that are right tires riders
duke it isn't you just know it's Stephen
King imagine himself in the scenario
yeah yeah it looks really cool thank you
guys for all notifying us it was out hey
subscribe to the real rejects reasons
your
on Twitter and Instagram he's a social
media manager the real rejects and blum
house you've heard of that horror movie
company and once again
go watch the ghost hunter Diaries link
in description box